[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
más
a
[Música]
[Risas]
aa
[Música]
[Risas]
o
e
[Música]
vivo
ah
e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias
es un privilegio vivir esta época ser
músico en esta época
porque ahora podemos a través de
diversas formas tener contacto con
muchas culturas con muchas expresiones
musicales
siempre hemos crecido con una idea
universalmente
creída o inducida de qué
la música es como un valor para todos
universal y yo siempre he cuestionado
esa idea digo a lo mejor no es
políticamente correcto decirlo lo digo
no la música no está tan universal
porque
a ver pónganle vaya mañana en su comida
familiar y pongan a ligeti a ver si es
universal
y liggett es autor así contemporáneo del
siglo 20 vamos a ver que no es tan
universal no opongan una misa de baja en
un lugar de reggaeton y van a ver que no
es universal lo que existe universal es
la necesidad del hombre de hacer música
y eso siempre ha estado constante y es
como una cuestión que se rastrea
en la noche de los tiempos así
y el humano ha tenido la posibilidad de
crear muchísimas músicas de hecho los
investigadores creen que cada clan que
había en la prehistoria tenía un tipo de
música particular único
claro con el desarrollo del tiempo esto
ha cambiado y cada vez se va perdiendo
mucho esa variedad
y
con los procesos de homogenización y de
digamos de expansión cultural pues
muchas músicas se pierden se extinguen
así como lenguas instrumentos especies
también animales etcétera
va cambiando el tiempo quizá en un
futuro no muy lejano vamos a tener una
realmente una música universal justo con
el big data y todas estas cosas que
están apareciendo por eso ha sido como
mi necesidad de mi amor por la música de
probar sonidos muy diferentes como este
que ustedes que acaban de escuchar que
es de tailandia que el instrumento se
llama que en que es un órgano de boca y
pero no he querido tocarlo con música
tradicional de allá porque es difícil de
además no le veo mucho el caso sino
hacer uno
un sonido nuevo de sonidos ancestrales
que justamente es lo que yo he pensado y
bueno ahora para concluir voy a tocar
otro instrumento de origen de una nación
que ahora está en china este que se
llama el instrumento se llama julios y
gracias
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
i
ghana
e
ah
en
a mí
[Música]
e
[Risas]
[Música]
a bajar
e
[Música]
ah
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]